so according to new research you didn't
just get older during the pandemic
you got fatter new research reveals
americans gained
roughly 20 pounds since the pandemic
began
which begs the question compared to what
seriously i feel like i gained 20 pounds
a year
then i spend the next year losing it but
aside from having no control group
it makes some sense shut everyone down
exercise space becomes limited
your companion becomes a flat screen if
you don't have an exercise and diet
system in place you're gonna get fat
it's not good covid triggered the
shutdown
that made sure its one common risk
factor only grew
obesity covid is a pro at
self-preservation
but it's too bad we couldn't talk about
obesity early on i'd say it's the
elephant in the room of risk
but then a teen vogue editor would try
to cancel me but avoidance for the sake
of feelings
kills excess fat makes it hard to take
deep breaths
which for covet an illness that impairs
lung function
puts you already in a deep hole it also
boosts risk
risk for impaired immune function and
chronic inflammation
the world obesity federation reports
that in countries where more than half
the population is overweight
death rates are 10 times higher than
other nations that's amazing
seems like something the press should
have led with early on
i mean they love to raise awareness
about all sorts of stuff
including fat acceptance but with this
they just couldn't say it at least out
loud because journalists have feelings
especially when they catch themselves in
the mirror
all right i was going to ask everybody
here if they gained or lost weight but
i'm not sure i
should jesse it is obvious you put on
the pounds oh my god
i don't know how you can even squeeze
yourself into that suit
anyway no control group do you buy this
do you buy this study i think you're
right i think we mentioned it last week
on the show that obesity
is right behind age in the terms of risk
factor for the deadliness of covid
so we had a big opportunity in america
to make america
get outside and exercise again and
instead we just shut everybody down
in a small apartment or home where covid
transmits at the highest level
we shut down parks we arrested gym
owners yeah shut down beaches
and even gavin newsom has still
prohibited
volleyball tournaments beach volleyball
tournaments in california
they have a thousand miles of coastline
non-contact sport
you can't play beach volleyball in
california people don't get it
i don't get it it was an easy solution
yeah juan it seems like we missed the
boat here with
just getting people outside to walk i
think in la they even closed down
skateboard parks
they filled it up with sand crazy
i mean you know we had a lockdown and we
still lost more than 500 000 people how
many people
you know would be good i don't get it to
my mind
you know the greatest generation people
in world war ii went off to fight
wars in europe and asia all we're
talking about here
is eat a salad take a walk you know what
i'm saying
stop watching access hollywood you know
do a push-up that's
i mean what's to make a big deal out of
that for protecting our health though
but you know what i think um yeah
definitely kennedy i think the point the
thing is is
people kind of need to have like a
backup plan for eating
and exercising in times of crisis
because
you don't you never think about that but
that actually would be a good idea
maybe you know what happened for a lot
of people their circadian rhythms were
thrown off
because now all of a sudden people are
sleeping much later in the day
and have so many stress hormones just
bombarding their system so much cortisol
that even if you do have an eating plan
and an exercise plan
you're still at risk for gaining weight
but when they shut all the gyms and
pools
i couldn't believe that i'm looking at
this going okay
people who are healthy want to go to the
gyms and get healthier
chlorine kills bugs yeah probably should
shut down the pools and then go home and
order a bunch of chipotle
yeah there you go dana you've obviously
lost a lot of weight during the pandemic
despite the
enormous amount of edibles you're
ingesting yeah
even though i can't i can't even see to
find my edibles
[Laughter]
i mean will edibles fix this because yes
i need help
um yes a couple things you guys remember
when they started putting
uh crime tape around the soccer fields
but the science the cdc was saying it's
okay to be outside to exercise
yeah even without a mask i was like it
was okay get some fresh air and that we
weren't following the science
but the other thing here greg we haven't
mentioned is the drinking yes
and a lot of the studies showing that a
huge amount of increase in drinking
especially wine all
we all know that converts to sugar sugar
i know
yes exactly i look at it every day
sadly so does my wife